the final four is headed to Indiana you
all know that where the state where the
state just passed a law that
discriminates against gay people yeah
just wait until Indiana finds out all
those players shower together
[Applause]
this is how I shower actually I have two
loofahs right yeah and Angele going and
you're wearing a suit yeah bring a suit
and tie no but people are upset the
anti-gay law is so bad it could affect
the tournament it could affect the
tournament yeah yeah at the games the
vendors are gonna make you explain
exactly what you plan to do with that
foam finger so
take it away from you yeah yeah take
away your foam finger that's sheriff's
door I apologize
people are imagining right now Oh a lot
of chatter about the upcoming
presidential race the ex governor of
Maryland martin O'Malley said quote the
presidency of the United States is not
some crown to be passed between two
families yeah
Jeb Bush said that's true which should
really just belong to one family I think
I thought this is kind of cool an iPad
used by the Pope you don't hear that
often an iPad used by the Pope is being
auctioned off for charity
yeah when asked why the Pope said I gave
up candy crush for Lent
[Applause]
Atlanta Falcons in the news the Atlanta
Falcons are coming under fire for
pumping fake crowd noise into their
stadium during football games fake yeah
you could tell it was fake because on
third down the fans would chant Wheel of
Fortune there's a new app out there
that's right a new app gang no the big
news there's been a new app what did you
just drop over there I dropped my
glasses cuz about that new app
there's he just heard something and I
saw you running to get something we're
human
I got it I got a CD what's that oh yeah
put him on
I like them I love Bilhah they're way
down your nose well that's their like my
reading list yeah I like that
see now I look smart not what do you not
when you say that where was I oh yeah
new app out there there's a new app that
helps you find missing dogs using facial
recognition technology that's cool yeah
there's also a companion app for dogs to
find their owners using crotch
recognition technology
[Applause]
people didn't really laugh at that one
they more applauded the idea that would
work
that's a well it would work very well
absolutely
Apple Apple announced it will only sell
the Apple watch in the store by
appointment in the store by appointment
yeah and a related story Casio announced
it will only be selling its watches in a
van behind the chick-fil-a the Navajo
Nation has decided to add a 2% tax on
junk food 2% tax yes the junk food tax
was opposed by respected Navajo leader
chief binges on Hot Pockets California
ladies and gentlemen California has run
out of room to house its death row
inmates which is why they're all here in
my audience
[Applause]
Wow
and what a techy group they
[Laughter]
you